i think the problem is there is some
validity to the rage
and that is that we kind of do live in a
patriarchy i've been thinking a lot
about this our father who art
in heaven it's like the whole christian
religion is based off
my my heavenly father like there's like
a divine masculine
why isn't a woman because you're the
divine feminine
you guys don't function without us men
are the warriors men are our strengths
and women
are the empathy and compassion and the
caregiving
we have our roles and our roles are
equally as awesome and i don't see it as
a patriarchy i i see it as
you're willing to go out there and
slaughter animals and hang it off my
balcony and
skin it and feed me then you know what
you deserve some
some respect and so do i because i am
the life giver
even though i kind of got cheated out of
that one but
i am the life giver so i i don't know i
i see us as very equal and if you look
through our history there's a lot
of celebration of women i think we just
choose not to see it so we could be mad
ian you need to understand um women um
have been the pro have always women have
always been the primary victims of war
says hillary clinton women lose their
husbands their fathers their sons in
combat so heartbreaking
that's an actual quote from hillary
clinton oh that's circulation let me let
me read you this question
hillary clinton said women have always
been the primary victims of war
women lose their husbands their fathers
their sons in combat
now this was considered to be pretty
funny by a lot of people because it's
like dude those people died
like defending you're not the victim
like those people who
died are the victims but i'll put it
this way first of all
snopes says the ratings is true she
actually said it
patriarchy so while the men go off and
die
and the women are victims because the
men sacrifice themselves to save the
women
the men were the ones it was the
patriarchy i just think that
patriarchy is this idea used to generate
support for some kind of
movement that gives someone power it's
that simple it's like the idea that men
are secretly dominating society like
it's specifically men and not women like
men are trying to control the women and
i do see that like
really where were the complaints from
the women on the titanic when they were
the only ones allowed to board the life
ships
and all of you guys with your male
privilege were sent into the icy waves
to die
i didn't hear anything about patriarchy
women were the divine
we were protected by our men there's a
reason
because men are savages so we find good
men to protect us from the savage men
and i think this utopia people have in
their brain that people are good
and are going to protect you is stupid
and it's it's unattainable it's never
going to happen
except the yin and the yang there's a
lot of evil
and we have the divine masculinity to
protect us ian think about
the noble rooster yes the
cockerel the mighty cockroach the
rooster will run
into a predator that it knows will kill
it at it
yells out a warning to the chickens who
run and hide and then it runs full speed
to the predator knowing it's gonna die
to save their lives yeah those chickens
got a matriarchy going on but hold on
do you know what happens if there's no
rooster and the chickens aren't doing
their thing they just get run up and
mauled by the predators
it's so we we actually had to deal with
this i know i'm making a kind of a joke
about chickens
but we were we were you know talking to
uh farmers and people who are chicken
experts about
just opening up the coop for the
chickens to come out and do their thing
and they were like yeah as long as you
have a rooster
i was like oh well we don't we we
actually didn't realize we had one at
the time but we didn't have a full grown
rooster
you can't you need you need that that
that uh
you need the rooster who defended the
villages exactly the women were
the warriors when their men were out
fighting to protect the divine feminine
and the children
if anyone came to that village you know
f around and find out that is what
happened like
try her try that woman at some point
what it seems like
some men or some people decided let's
build a system where men are in control
so that if
stuff hits the fan we can protect the
women so like they still
won't let you think you're in control
women are the most highly manipulative
creatures on this earth the fact that
you guys walk around
thinking you've oppressed us as all
we've done
is legit chess pieces with you
simpletons
i mean we love you she's right
of college students are female right now
and they're saying they're the ones who
are oppressed
they're the ones who have the college
degrees and are starting to make more
money if you look at the gender wage gap
it's not even
real and yet men are just like okay and
they're trying to pass
laws that keep empowering women yeah it
goes it goes back
it goes deeper than america every king
had a really
really smart manipulative wife or like
six of them
yeah and you are going to be kicked out
of the club because you've just exposed
their secrets
yeah your secrets care none of you are
my friends
you guys are evil and vindictive and
manipulative
and that's why i don't hardly have any
friends it was very hard to find
some that didn't do it back it's true
girls aren't nice
vicious we are not nice and i have long
said that women are the neck that turns
the head this is 100 remember in ancient
rome where he's like
we will murder you all if you gossip and
they're like ha ha
we will continue no i haven't heard that
story
yeah they're like we will continue to
just i have friends that catfish
married couples men just to make them
divorce
and took joy in it and they didn't even
know and then tell me later and i'm like
girl you are
messed up we're mean look at this ian
guy he's all like we're actually in
charge i'm sorry i was just concerned
with the system like there are
individual
bouts of craziness on all sides but it
it
saying that god is a man is crazy to me
i was about to let loose
god made adam and was like oh man what a
mistake i can
yeah god made
all man dominated and it was written by
dudes and uh
i can do better so he made better well
this is what
would you looks like think about
political power
would you rather be the face sitting
beneath the sword of damocles everyone
knows who you are knows who to come
after
or the shadow power behind it the
financiers i like the shadow power
i like the strategist so women don't
both position we don't want to sit there
men are the ones the proud peacocking
look at my feathers i'm so great and
women are like
i'm in the shadows plotting your demise
and you don't even
know it actually but but let's like to
to be honest to be real
i wouldn't say they're planning the
demise obviously it's a joke but they
are planning
their comfort saying you know he's gonna
he's gonna for the longest time you have
this system where
some women felt it was oppressive and in
some ways it was there was social
enforcement like
women typically didn't have jobs so it
was hard for those who did
but they also didn't have to go to i
don't know petroleum rigs and lose their
arms or go wait around in sewers
pulling rat kings from that's why they
didn't want to vote they're like we
don't want
in that crap like there's a whole bunch
of women they're like we don't want
part of this garbage that these idiots
are in
you used to have to be in some places uh
uh in order to vote you had to be
signed up for the fire brigade things
like that and so
if you ask modern leftists they'll tell
you oh that was all propaganda take away
women's rights to vote and everything
so they wouldn't get it but they're
actually women who are like you mean i
have to sign up for the fire brigade i
don't want to do that let them take care
of it
it used to be that service guaranteed
citizenship
to a certain degree right if you wanted
the right to vote there was some
responsibility expected in your
contribution to the community
and just it started to erode it used to
be that voting came with
responsibilities and eventually said
universal universal suffrage you know
you just vote everybody votes
now that's been exploited to a great
degree and my opinion's actually been
shifting on it a bit
especially after i saw jon stewart and
this is an old article where he said
that we should jon stewart said we
should bring back the draft in some form
because people have lost their sense of
community he wasn't saying like military
draft
he was effectively saying service
guarantee citizenship do something for
your community
to prove you care about it and then you
know he i don't tie it to voting i still
love
john because he's not annoying he went
away and he was like i'm not going to be
like every other celebrity on twitter
look at how annoying i am
i'm all know it like shut up i love that
guy be funny
back at the 20 bill man just be funny
and that's what he is he's a brilliant
brilliant man but yeah
women aren't victims and when you don't
think of yourself as a victim
it's just not there i don't i don't see
it because i'm no one's victim i go in
the rooms and i command them
like i'm not like oh i'm not in charge
here there's a man
like i've never felt that way and once a
chick feels that way
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy yeah
that's for sure that's why the crt
stuff bothers me yeah i don't think that
people are victims
but it does seem like the system was set
up by men
to empower give men like a foothold
with the whole god as a man men were
strong the the venetian patriarchy was
like all about the
the old or the wealthiest man would
control the family's money and run the
city and so when you put a man at the
top of the hierarchy who does he have
behind him
who is he supporting who is he pulling
up with him he's pulling up his family
dude my man goes out and hacks down
trees and drags
300 pound logs across a field and if i
commanded him to do something for me
and it was reasonable he would do it 100
and i
love it we're equal but i know that like
he would die for me this like
powerhouse would put himself first like
i feel great over here i'm a queen
and who uh who did they kill in the
french revolution
well the king and the queen exactly yeah
gender doesn't
no look look look uh i certainly think
it's obvious that sexism
has existed for a long time and
certainly there's been institutional
misogyny in
many ways and we've overcome those
things but to act like women were
powerless look at cleopatra she floated
egypt longer than it should have been
floated with the power
between her legs she was like wait a
minute i can manipulate
all these julius caesar i think marc
antony
like she was going for it and she egypt
would have fallen
years before but she was cunning and she
was smart and they say she wasn't even
that hot
she just knew what to do yeah she killed
her sister i think that was her sister
was trying to kill her so she had her
killed herself
she was uh well she was a direct
descendant of alexander the great's
uh second commit or first in command and
they
inbred the whole time so i'm sure
something was going crazy because they
all kept it in the family so they were
like greek that's why when everyone's
like cleopatra was this color i'm like
cleopatra
was great okay let's just be real am i
wrong that
that we live in like a patriarchal yes
christianity is like pictures you have
been
brainwashed by a bunch of weak idiots
that want me to be a victim but am i not
am i right
is it true that christianity is
patriarchal i don't see
the catholicism is patriarchal i think
the answer to that is yes
okay look eve went and she did what she
wanted
she was like i'm gonna do what i want
and then the dude suffered for it just
like my husband does
every day when i make decisions right
so i don't find it like the patriot i
don't know i just look at the world
differently
and once you do like you just don't feel
it i think it used to be
a little sucky but like i walk around
every single day
like armed and i feel good
the great equalizer on me i'm just like
whatever
i'm powerful i don't like it sounds like
you're saying that men
sort of planned this yeah but it it i
just don't see that
i think when you look at we talked about
this in a bunch of our dating segments
if you have a hundred men and one woman
your civilization is in serious danger
if you have 100 women and one man you'll
actually your civilization will probably
thrive because you can have a lot more
kids that natural
component of human existence means
there's always going to be a bias in
favor of protecting women as more
valuable
just like the rooster sacrificing
himself if you have a hundred men and a
hundred women
you can sac you can lose 99 men in
battle and your
tribe your your village your town will
survive
not so much the other way around that's
why in like there was
raping and pillaging it meant to steal
but they would take the women because
the women were the most important thing
so you you you look at that from an
evolutionary perspective or
a sociological perspective and over time
you're going to see more and more
institutions rise up
solely to protect women i can certainly
imagine at a certain point it became
overbearing
and especially as we've become safer and
safer we have secured the borders of
this country or at least we did a while
ago to the point
where it's totally it's it's way safer
now you don't got to worry about
banditos coming in and
viking raiders storming the beaches and
stealing your women
so now we don't need a lot of those
protections but to act like we're more
powerless when they were the ones that
were basically
the reason for the can we make this
nerdy game of thrones circe lannister in
season one or two
coward in the red keep as all the men
fought and she was scared oh my god
stannis is gonna come kill me
that diabolical scheming broad near the
end you knew who was in power she killed
her
husband she did all this horrible crap
to everyone
yeah your brother had bastard children
everything
wrong that happened in king's landing
was because of her and then she sat on
the iron throne like
yep i did it so who was in power ian
who wasn't using game of thrones it was
seriously
cersei was running until those stones
smashed her head in i mean it was her
dad
until season eight destroyed all our
lives
was like i should have kept ahead of the
show i was hoping there was a troll
every moment i'm like he's just going to
come out it's just a big troll like me
and chad
it's just a troll it's all a lie i'm
blackpilled there was never any books he
ran out of ideas they got a wretch on it
yeah
they can do that just rewrite season
five six and seven well it's it's it's
like there's there's a show called uh a
full metal alchemist you've ever heard
of it
i've heard of it i've heard of it it's
an anime so uh
the way the way they do they use the way
they do anime is like someone will write
the comic version
and then they'll start animating you
know a month so
like they're on chapter 10 they're
making episode one of the show
and so the the comic is always ahead of
the show in this instance the comic
stopped and the show kept going
and then they later came back and redid
a new branch of the show with the new
storyline so
if they decide to redo seasons seven and
eight with like the new fixed writing
cgi like when they make like oh our
young cr
uh kurt russell and uh not avengers
snake pliskin ant-man not ant-man the
really cool ones
the with stupid guardians of the galaxy
yes
yes i always forget that i have like a
little hate in my heart i'll tell you
guys off camera
who's uh who's who played the guy in
ant-man the old guy i don't even see it
i can't remember
oh uh oh you know yeah wasn't he the one
that got throat cancer from
cunnilingus oh what wasn't he married
catherine zetta jones oh that's michael
douglas
yes yes they de-aged him and ant-man oh
wow he's like a young version and
and in the avengers there's like a
really like a 20 year old version
and i thought it's pretty good so they
could do that for game of thrones
problem fix we're good
just give me like a stick figure
animation explaining the fixed version
of it i'm satisfied
like here's the quick synopsis we picked
the storyline i'm sure
jon snow can say something besides i
don't want it she's mcqueen
dude they should have brought ned stark
back i mean come on guys
use magic usually bring him back he's
reunite the starks that would have been
the best when they stole danny's dragons
in the houses of the undying she had
visions of him
without his head and rob stark with a
wolf on his head and they didn't show
and i was like damn that would have been
real cool
anyway i'm sorry i took us way off
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you